ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
channel today we have an exciting
episode of colts going to war
two of the biggest cults on earth right
now it's the elon musketeers versus the
bitcoin boys twitter's going nuts right
now
elon musk is the enemy of the bitcoin
boys the elon musk fans they say hey
it's all about dogecoin
and look at the end of the day it's just
cringe on both sides and i'm gonna play
both sides
right i'm gonna play a little mac from
always sunny in philadelphia i get
myself into too much trouble this time
i'm playing both sides so that i always
come out on top dude
it honestly feels so it's like such a
big war it feels like a mr beast
went to war with pewdiepie like youtube
wouldn't know what to do with themselves
they'd implode right
and it's objectively funny watching
these people look the maturity of
elon musketeers and bitcoin boys it's
not much more than nine-year-olds or
ten-year-olds like
half of them think that digital money is
going to make everybody rich who buys it
and the other half thinks that elon
musk's going to put a nano chip
inside of your brain inside of two years
so both side i think are a little bit
wrong
at the same time i'm kind of a fan look
i own a little satoshi
i own a little bit of uh actually i
don't think a musk
but i like musk right so with that out
of the way with covering both of my
bases with appeasing both sides because
i don't know who's going to win yet
let's get let's jump into this story
right let's go to the board
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla
and yeah so to give you all a little bit
of backstory
about how this massive battle started
right
elon musk announcing back in march that
you can now
buy a tesla with bitcoin now bear in
mind crypto
is still sort of a new thing even though
it's getting wider acceptance
and something as big as tesla sort of
publicly announcing that they're going
to start using this
as a transaction like that you can
actually transact and buy a real thing
with bitcoin was a big deal and it was a
sign that crypto was here to stay
additionally tesla even took bitcoin
onto their
balance sheet according to a 10k filing
they had put 1.5 billion dollars
into bitcoin elon musk even called
bitcoin a slightly less
dumb version than cash he was pretty
much like beloved by everyone at this
point
he's the hero to crypto there's no
betrayal he's just
pro bitcoin everybody's excited everyone
wants to talk to him
all of crypto follows him and they're
all loved by tesla's cyber trucks
they're putting in their pre-orders
he literally gets everybody on his side
then he even promises to put a literal
dogecoin on the literal moon i mean this
man
is loved by everyone so what could go
wrong
fast forward a month and uh tesla does a
stress test
they do they prove wanted to prove
liquidity by selling bitcoin they wanted
to prove that it could be a viable cash
alternative and people understandably
start to get nervous they wonder
is tesla really in this for the long
haul is he a bitcoin maximalist
what is he doing here and many thought
that this was proof that maybe elon musk
was getting cold feet about the whole
project but then
the fire nation attacked ladies and
gentlemen put the ominous music on
because on may 12th elon musk puts out
this tweet
tesla and bitcoin basically they say
they're not going to accept bitcoin uh
for tesla
anymore like they won't accept it as a
form of payment because of
it's quote great cost to the environment
uh which i guess elon musk is saying he
just found out about
and so everybody loved this except for
the bitcoiners
right bitcoin is freaked out so at this
point you can literally
see the second that he tweets because uh
bitcoin falls
from a high of like 57 000 to 50 000 in
like one tweet you know
the price of bitcoin by uh over 10 no
big deal guys
but honestly i think people miss how
genius of a troll this is because
not only is he manipulating the market
with his uh
you know movements here but i'm also
convinced that he didn't just now decide
and realize that
bitcoin was bad for the environment
literally the data has been out on this
forever you either believe it's a bad
thing or you believe it's a good thing
people disagree
but literally if he thinks that it's a
bad thing why did he say this
a month before this jack from twitter
ceo of twitter says
bitcoin incentivizes renewable energy
guys it's good for the environment
bitcoin isn't bad
we thought it was bad because elon musk
said so now it's good except you know
who else agrees with jack
elon musk who tweeted a month before
saying that it's too bad for the
environment he can't accept it for tesla
he said
true it is does incentivize renewable
energy
uh so not sure how to square that one
but either way the result was the same
bitcoin boys get furious and look i'm
not talking about like
random people who own bitcoin like
everybody does there's this special
breed i don't know if you know this
they're called bitcoin maximalists they
typically have uh
laser eyes in their profiles and they
basically think bitcoin is going to save
the world from everything but these guys
completely
lose their minds like elon musk poked
the bear when he caused uh
crypto to crash so i'm gonna be pulling
from barely sociable's twitter account
where he's been cataloging the meltdown
of some of these people check this out
dear jack i reported elon musk's account
because he's using his huge number of
followers that he gained
because being the richest man in the
world to manipulate the crypto market
and sure you know that what he is doing
with bitcoin kindly to sp suspend his
account or even warn him
about this manipulation as it is
affecting a lot of people negatively
hey guys the big bad billionaire made my
crypto account go down and i'm very mad
about
time to give elon the donald trump
treatment wow
when you see fudd click unsubscribe
thank you
now just bear in mind that the same guy
was worshiping elon musk like two months
ago this unsubscribed guy
where elon musk is talking about tesla
buying bitcoin and he goes
yeah that's what i thought said you
clearly like doge a lot personally which
is awesome
really appreciate you pushing awareness
of doge bitcoin and crypto
so literally these people they they love
you until you say anything negative and
then they go
unsubscribe flood this is useless
now to be fair i'm sure they would say
the same thing about him is that he
flip-flopped on bitcoin which
he did but all i'm saying is like the
second you criticize anything with
bitcoin they unsubscribe from you no
i i can't i can't listen dude this is
fun unsubscribe
follow it's like dude you're cringe
weren't you the guy saying
big fan hope to get a drink and maybe a
clubhouse session one day
we'll be so psyched is that you is this
you to be clear i don't know whether to
be upset that elon musk is like
definitely manipulating the market
or just be annoyed with these like
cringy crypto maximalists
i seriously don't know but uh you would
think that maybe
like that would be the end of it but of
course it's not because peter mccormack
then writes this long twitter thread
like dear elon musk it's a dear john
letter basically to elon musk
elon musk ends up replying obnoxious
threads like this make me want to go
all in on doge this guy isn't interested
in crypto he's he's a troll who loves
dogecoin
but then underneath it chain link god
2.0 basically says like well
it's adversarial but this guy's got a
point and elon musk says that actually
bitcoin is highly centralized
with a super majority being owned by a
handful of big mining companies
a single coal mine in xi jiang flooded
almost killing miners
and bitcoin hash rate dropped 35
sound decentralized to you now again
this isn't that bad of a point but it's
like did we not know this
a little while ago it feels like we did
and all of a sudden he sort of
cha making an about-face but i mean look
it's my personal opinion
that we have billionaires sort of
manipulating the market with impunity
and the sec doesn't seem to care to do
anything about it but at this point the
price of bitcoin is tanking even harder
like it's like dropping
once again because elon musk keeps
tweeting about it and so there's this
weird thing where like people are like
hey let's stop talking about elon musk
uh let's not talk about him he's gonna
he's gonna kill us he's gonna kill
krypto
we've pissed off the the sleeping giant
here
but then other people decided that he
should uh quote
pay for his sins which yeah that that
doesn't sound like a cult at all
like what are you guys doing man i would
almost be on your side to be against
this market manipulation
but it's like so cringe what you guys do
literally look at this
sorry but someone had to say it i don't
give an
f that you're rich and popular i'm not
scared of you humanity gains nothing
from your ego
humanity gains everything from bitcoin
i will die oh my gosh
you're gonna give your life for bitcoin
for internet money i mean look
i like bitcoin not gonna die for a
dollar you know what i mean
i will die by the fire so at this point
some
sort of like contrarian accounts get
involved i like this guy mr
whale and he basically says that
bitcoiners are gonna slap themselves
next quarter
when they find out that tesla dumped the
rest of their bitcoin holdings
with the amount of hate elon musk is
getting i wouldn't blame that him
where elon musk then decides hm i
haven't manipulated the market in like
five minutes and goes
indeed like this is this is basically
saying
tesla's sold so of course everybody
panics
uh because they think elon musk is
abandoning bitcoin elon musk is
abandoning bitcoin he's gonna abandon us
he's already gonna go all in on doge now
bitcoin's done doge the next big thing
so bitcoin crashes again and um
that's basically i think where we've
kind of left it is big elon musk has
basically ditched bitcoin for doge i
kind of think to myself like
what's the big deal i mean look if it's
a great currency it's gonna get used
regardless of whether some
billionaire uses it or not it's like
some kind of insecurity here if you
think that so easily
bitcoin's gonna get replaced if you know
some big twitter account
thinks so and like pushes it i don't
know i i think you don't believe in your
currency enough as like
useful you know what i mean and now
that's pretty much where we leave it i
mean elon musk is sort of passively
uh aggressively like liking and
retweeting things like
truth let's do this about ditching
bitcoin to go for doge
or doge is the people's coin i don't
know anyone irl with bitcoin
but no dozens with doge it's kind of
like he's a little upset he's hurt
meanwhile the bitcoin maximalists are
hurt and they hate elon musk
it's sort of this interesting arc where
elon sort of become the villain of the
crypto community
and i just can't help thinking it's the
whole thing's absolutely hilarious
although is it market manipulation
almost definitely i mean the sec just
doesn't care
like dude when millionaires and
billionaires manipulate the market the
sec couldn't care less but if you
manipulate the market with
you know a 10 000 follower twitter
account you're gonna
you're gonna get slapped immediately
that's kind of how it goes kind of
pathetic but which cult do you think's
gonna win
do you think bitcoin satoshi is gonna
take down
elon musk i never thought it was
possible but
who knows who knows his egos hurt the
bitcoin community's ego's heart
uh let's find out he might
single-handedly bring down crypto i mean
who knows
my portfolio is in the red let's just
say that for now
anyways thanks for watching i hope that
brings you up to date on this ridiculous
petty story i mean i know this feels
like it's like drama alert like we're
keemstar right now you know
talk like reporting on this petty drama
but at the same time you have to bear in
mind
that hundreds of billions of dollars are
being liquidated right now
so it kind of is a gigantic story even
though it's so stupid it's just like
a bunch of egos and then elon musk being
like herder i care about the environment
today but not
yesterday it's anyway it's ridiculous
all right thanks for watching i'll see
you guys in the next one